partout sur internet des articles de
presse rapportent les condamnation pour
travail dissimulé
le 17 mai dernier ce célèbre pilote
automobile est condamné par le tribunal
correctionnel d'albertville à 40000
euros damende dont 20000 avec sursis la
justice point des irrégularités dans
l'emploi de travailleurs bulgares sur
ces chalets en bois les travailleurs
détachés véritable hantise pour david
bertrand
cet artisan menuisier emploie neuf
salariés qualifiés
labellisé rg eux ils possèdent
l'assurance décennale un coût financier
important qui lui assure toutefois une
certaine crédibilité
mais régulièrement il est confronté à
des concurrents qui font appel à des
salariés étrangers non déclarés et donc
moins cher antoine en fait le point sur
les assemblages
ici tu as les assemblages le nombre de
boulons pour la partie entre et poinçon
on forme des gens on commence par des
apprentis à prend forme aux salariés
ça c'est paris ça a un coût d'un pouvoir
d'aider des gens compétents dans nos
entreprises les travailleurs détachés ce
qui sera formé est-ce qu'il va
travailler avec des échafaudages avec
toutes les normes qui sont en vigueur
dans les métiers du bâtiment aussi bien
pour employer les matériaux
que pour wii que la sécurité et ses
recoins le travailleurs détachés n'est
pas interdit ce sont les conditions qui
encadrent le détachement qui peuvent
être condamnable dans le cadre d'une
prestation de service international une
entreprise française peut faire appel à
une entreprise étrangère
celle ci met à disposition des
travailleurs pour que le cadre soit
légal
ces travailleurs doivent posséder un
certificat de rattachement à leur
sécurité sociale l'entreprise doit
exister légalement et posséder une
activité substantielle si ces critères
ne sont pas remplies le travail devient
dissimuler les ouvriers sont détachés
illégalement pour lutter contre ces
mauvaises pratiques
plusieurs organismes dont l'urssaf maine
près de 580 contrôles par an on observe
une hausse du montant des redressements
que ce soit au niveau national
d'avancement de progresser en trois
camps dans lyon 2 650 millions d'euros
notifié au niveau national nous nous
somme d'environ 2 3 7 millions d'euros
notifiant franche comté c'est une hausse
également et puis cette tendance à la
hausse va se poursuivre en tout cas pour
la région franche comté de manière assez
nette l'année prochaine puisque
plusieurs gros dossiers vont sortir sont
sortis déjà en début d'année 2010 neuf
donc au petit de l'année 2019
on va voir un montant de redressement
beaucoup plus important que au titre de
l'humaniser david bertrand et tous les
autres patrons les et ont conscience que
la concurrence déloyale existe aussi à
cause du manque de main d'oeuvre en
france
alors pour tenter d'améliorer les choses
leur confédération
la capeb souhaite revaloriser la filière
grâce à une formation plus adaptée nous
nourrit et maintenant ça faisait 40
euros d'or 1
voilà et en plus après il ya les charges
selon lui a le rire des tâches et bien
peu il touche il va peut-être touché pas
maudit chinoise est de 10 euros de
l'heure c'est même pas si c'est un semis
je pense qu'il faudrait former plus de
gens faudrait inciter
plus de gens offrir une formation dans
le bâtiment s'intéresser aux petites
entreprises du bâtiment métiers du
bâtiment restauration gardiennage tous
les secteurs sont concernés en cas de
travail illégal un chef d'entreprise
peut être condamné à trois ans de prison
et à une amende allant jusqu'à 225 mille
euros et voir sa condamnation relaté sur
internet